what I want to do in this video is
explore how a floating exchange rate
could in theory help resolve trade
imbalances and for this simplified
example we're going to assume that the
exchange rate between the Chinese when
and the US dollar is six when per one
u.s. dollar and also for simplification
we're going to assume that China is only
exporting one thing to the United States
and that one thing is microwaves and at
six UN per dollar the Chinese
manufacturer is going to sell them in
the United States for $50 each and at
that price there's demand in the United
States for 1 million microwaves I'm also
going to assume that the only export
from the u.s. to China is software and
they have demand for 2 million units if
they sell them at 60 when per unit so
let's think about what the demand for
each of the currencies will be from each
of the manufacturers so the Chinese
manufacturer over here is going to sell
a million units at fifty dollars each so
he's going to get 50 million dollars in
revenue and he is going to want to
convert that 50 million dollars into
into yuan so you can kind of view this
as the supply this right over here is
the supply of US Dollars and we're going
to see that these are the only people
that are trading currencies because
these are only people trading in this
ultra simplified world now the u.s.
manufacturer is going to sell two
million units at sixty one each so
that's going to be 120 million 120
million yuan of revenue and he's going
to want to convert this into dollars at
the prevailing exchange rate right then
which is six one per dollar so he is
going to want to convert this you divide
this in by six he's going to wanted to
convert that into twenty million dollars
and obviously he wants to convert into
when because that's what his costs are
and that's where he lives
this guy wants to convert in two dollars
because that's where his costs are now
this is a supply of dollars these
dollars want to be converted into
Chinese currency this right here is the
demand for dollars this is the amount of
dollars needed
a guy converting from one now clearly
there's an imbalance the supply of
dollars is much larger than the demand
for dollars in this situation and
anytime the supply for anything is
larger than the demand if the supply if
the supply is larger than demand then
that means that the price the price must
go down when we talk about the price of
a currency in this case the price of the
dollar going down we're talking about in
terms of U n so the dollar the dollar
will go down the price goes down which
means the when goes up the dollar will
become weaker the when will become
stronger now if that happens what
happens to the prices over here if the
yet we when becomes stronger and we
start seeing for what v wind per dollar
or for one per dollar even three wins
per dollar
then this Chinese manufacturer won't be
able to afford to sell it at only $50 he
is going to have to raise the price in
order to cover his cost in Chinese
currencies if he raises the price he's
going to lower the demand on the other
side of the equation the American
manufacturer in order to get the same
number of dollars he actually can sell
it for fewer one now he needs fewer one
per each dollar so he can actually lower
the price in China and if he lowers the
price in China that's going to increase
the demand so what you have happening is
because the wand would become stronger
if you had a floating exchange rate the
demand for Chinese Goods would go down
and the demand for US goods would go up
and eventually you would have this in
this trade and currency imbalance
resolve itself now this is all
theoretical and the reality is that it's
not that it's not allowed to float and
we'll describe that more in future
videos this is Salman Khan from the Khan
Academy for CNBC